let's as as usual let's begin by reading
what's going on trout and cop types of
fish a lake contains a number of trout
at a certain time ten carp is the lake
it's not eating a trout jerks as a
consequence the number of trout and
decreases according to that equation
where T is the time in months after a
carp are introduced the population of
carp P increases according to that
equation it's a differential equation
and then they start to ask a series of
questions just pause for a moment
what makes this question hard well when
you have a look it's in question 16 you
think oh right this is at the end of the
paper right here 1 to 10 multiple-choice
11 through 16 are your extended response
they've tuck this in here this monster
of a question because they want to make
this a challenging as challenging as a
two-unit
exponential growth and decay question
pretty much gets okay the example we
looked at before with the salt water and
that kind of thing that's extension one
growth in decay because if you have a
look at the differential equation have a
look the differential equation you have
here you see how it's just 0.02 P all
right there's no P minus this or P minus
that so this is still to unit but it's
very challenging because we have not
just one exponential growth situation
but we have to write and somehow we've
got to have them interacting with each
other right so let's start to unpack
this part one how many trout in the lake
when the carp were introduced so when I
say part one there are two equations
which is the one to do with trout is it
N or is it Pete it's n okay so I'm going
to go straight to the equation I'll
actually gonna write down the equation
for N and equals and they give us some
stuff in here 375 - is it 0.04 T yep yep
there's my equation for the number of
trout now they say they use words right
this is part of what's an issue in this
whole topic if I pop coming read the
words and think about what value you're
gonna have to put in to this equation it
says when the carp were introduced
used re carefully what time value is
that that's time zero because it says T
is the type of months after the carp are
introduced so the carp are introduced at
time zero so let's go ahead we can work
this out
when T equals zero right when you have a
look think about what's going to happen
up in that index where the index is zero
what does this whole exponential term
become one what do you think is the most
common trap that students fall into when
they see all zero they say oh it's just
zero because there's some students zero
but it's not of course an equals 375
take away one that means you had this
many trout thumbs up okay I know how
many trout we started with when will the
trout population be zero
part two okay so I'm still dealing with
this same equation it in bless you right
but I'm going to substitute in something
different what am I going to substitute
you to this instead of T equals zero I'm
going to substitute in N equals zero
that's when they're all gone so you're
gonna have this 375 - that that's going
to equal zero okay so we can go ahead
and we can lucky about with this we're
going to have to rearrange we're gonna
take logs of both sides can I let you do
that or give you a bit of time to work
out your value of T
anyone there what do you offer we dot
okay so every time you get an enhancer
out after you've done all of your
operations and manipulation you see have
I answered the question as of this line
I have not answered the question it says
when will the population of trout be
zero so I need to provide something
about time so I think it would be nice
and neat to say at the end right this
will be when after one hundred and forty
eight months okay with that yes now just
a really minor note some people are
going to be sorry if you about this
because if you actually sub e in t
equals 148 back into this equation go
ahead you've got a calculator there
right what do you actually get 335 minus
e to the zero point zero four times that
do you get zero actually zero no decimal
places or anything when you 748 though
is what I'm asking seven again two point
five eight there are a two hole trout
that are still alive right you like is
this actually the answer okay now the
reason why I'm going to defend this
answer and they accept actually both if
you justify it at the HSC is because
what is this is this actually like at
some point in time is there going to be
half a trout or point five eight over
trout all those kinds of things not
really this is just a model right it's
just a model it's a very good one it's
very useful one but we don't actually
get that your individual trout level of
precision it's like well I'm going to
have that trout's gonna I'm going to
tell you exactly the minute and hour
that you're going to die because my
model tells you this it can't do that
doesn't have that kind of precision okay
so an approximation is just fine that
was part two what does part three ask
can you have a look at it for me
okay so we actually want to get a
picture of this they actually do tell
you we want a drawing okay now I'm gonna
go ahead and I'm really gonna draw a
first quadrant on this why do you think
that might be what would the UM what
were the left-hand side the negative
part of that what would that represent
in a situation like this that will have
a look what what the honor on next video
graph I'm usually using horizontal
access 44 time so that would be before
time zero I'm not interested in that
what about the negative access down here
you've got negative trout some
antimatter trout's floating around your
leg okay so I'm not interested in that
either your aunty trout's there they're
nicely they collide with charts minute
no I let each other I'm sorry I'm only
gonna have the positive access to reach
where do we start
how many trout do we have at the
beginning we've just worked this out in
part one 374 so I'm going to arbitrarily
pick a point make that 3 774 okay
after what time do we end how many trout
sorry how long have we gone when we say
no more trout left 148 months so I'm
gonna pick a spot
I'm Tralee now I know I'm going from
there to there this is an exponential
what kind of exponential shape am I
going to get hmm so if I didn't put any
kind of like restriction on this right I
would say that 375 is gonna move you
upwards right and this minus on the
front takes your exponential graph that
you're used to thinking like this and it
turns it upside down like that so you're
getting you're getting this kind of
shape right does that make sense but of
course I've cut off most of that I'm
only interested in a particular domain
and range because that's what makes
sense in this model so this is the
component that I'm interested in so
whoop there we go
happy times okay